today we hit an important milestone in  our vaccination campaign  more than half of all adults in the  european union have now had their  booster shot of covet-19 vaccine  and 82 of adults in the european union  are vaccinated  this is good  but of course we need to do more  everybody who can should get vaccinated  and get a booster shot  because the doctors and data have made  it very clear vaccination and boosters  provide the best protection against the  virus  and its variants including omicron  and data from our agency ecdc  shows that boosters can keep us out of  hospitals indeed  if all vaccinated people in the european  union got a booster  we could avoid around one million  hospitalizations in the european union  the pandemic is not over  and actually the omicron variant is  spreading really fast in many eu  countries  so let's protect ourselves